california more than 8 million people
have applied for unemployment benefits
tony we're keeping an eye on both
numbers jamie thank you very much the
surge in coronavirus cases is putting a
severe strain on hospitals all around
the country
and also on health care workers our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
miami for us
david good morning what's the situation
where you are
tony miami-dade county the most
populated county in the state has had
hospital
hospitals put in more requests to get
extra nurses to help out than any
other county in the state right now the
state tells cbs news they've gotten
about 51 hospital requests for nurses
they need about 2 000 nurses statewide
to help out but they've only found a
thousand
so far some of those nurses are working
here at jackson memorial one of the
largest hospitals of the state
and we spoke with the icu director
yesterday to get the latest
by the end of the week we will be a
hundred percent full
dr david delazerta is the lead icu
doctor at miami's jackson memorial
hospital he says they've opened a fifth
icu to handle the influx of patients
when normally they have just one
are the ones in the icu now younger are
they sicker
initially in this wave we start seeing
much a younger and sickest
and sicker patients when i meet seeker i
mean they using more icu resources they
use more oxygen they use more
medications to get their blood pressure
high
dr delazerta says patients youth
combined with the use of
anti-viral medication rem deserver
steroids and convalescent plasma
is helping to keep the mortality rate
lower about eight percent of icu
admissions
but patients are staying in the hospital
for much longer than before
i mean two or three weeks they can stay
in the icu and then go to the floor for
another two or three weeks so a covet
patient can stay in the system for
up to two months in miami-dade county
ten hospitals
now say they have zero or only one adult
icu bed available
medical assistant sammy diaz was
hospitalized with coronavirus back in
june
the 29 year old single mother of three
died 18 days later
i buried her on my birthday diaz's
mother anadelia diaz says her daughter
had
no underlying health conditions now
sammy's fifteen-year-old
two-year-old and one-year-old are
without their mom
are you now going to raise the kids yes
i am when she was in the hospital i said
to her
don't worry about the kids you know and
she says mom
i never worry about my kids when they're
with you
sammy's 30th birthday was two days after
her mother buried her
one more thing before we go we're
keeping a close eye on what's happening
in louisiana
you know when louisiana had its hottest
hot spot moment it was centered around
new orleans
and it was right after mardi gras which
they think contributed to the rise in
cases
we spoke with a health official
yesterday gail who told us that now
there is covet throughout the state of
louisiana in
every single parish especially those
that have
fewer hospitals and need more resources
that seems to be how this story is going
david i'm still thinking